SPEAKER 1: They
point to the presence
of America in the
world's imagination,
even before America was settled.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So where do we begin this story?
History always begins
in the middle of things.
The Western hemisphere in
which we Americans live
was inhabited by people who
came from elsewhere, unwilling,
for the most part, to settle
for the conditions in which they
were born and drawn by the
possibility of a new life
or a new chance at life.
The lure of freedom, the space
to pursue their ambitions
in the way that whatever
old world they came from
did not permit.
The first settlers came
across the Bering Straits
from Northeastern
Asia and filtered down
into the settling of the
continent from the Yukon
down to Tierra Del
Fuego and South America.
We have the evidence of peoples
who have vanished since.
The Inca, the Maya, the
Aztecs, the grand civilizations
that flourished and flamed
out and died in various ways,
leaving behind splendid remnants
of their lives and livelihood.
We see in the North American
continent earthworks
and mounds--
burial mounds.
They're somewhat
mysterious, but that
are the remnants of
what we would call them
native or Indigenous peoples.
In ordinary American places
over the Midwest and the South,
we see remnants in the West
of the cliff dwelling people
the Anasazi or the Navajo
name, the Pueblo peoples who
are no longer there but have
left behind these structures.
There's something
haunting about this.
These civilizations
that were and have gone.
It's haunting to think
of the earliest explorers
before Columbus.
Leif Erikson who tried
to start a colony on what
is today the Canadian
island of Newfoundland.
He and other Norsemen
were trying their best
to establish a settlement,
and in a sense,
they could be called the
beginning of American history
but not really.
They're more like a false
start on American history,
and yet, they point to
the presence of America
in the world's imagination
even before America
was settled as an idea, the
presence of America as an idea.
A land of hope,
a land of refuge,
a land of opportunity of
that second chance at life
for those willing to take it.
It may seem a little bit
fanciful to attribute
that motive to the Asiatic,
the first Asiatic immigrants
to the Western hemisphere.
We don't know anything
about what they were doing.
They didn't leave any
remnants to indicate
one way or the other
what they had in mind.
We do know that the Norse
explorers were motivated
by an impulse to explore, to
find new lands and settle them.
So they were drawn by something
more than just necessity.
They were drawn by this prospect
of a new world, a new start,
and this was true 1,000 years
after Christ and 500 years
before Columbus.
There was already a
mystique about the West.
It was in the
literature of antiquity.
The ancient Greeks spoke
of the Isle of the blessed.
Homer located the Elysian
fields in the West.
That was where the stream
of the world's seas flowed.
Centuries later, Thomas More's
Utopia, Francis Bacon's New
Atlantis, these are all
expressions of this same theme,
the promise of the West.
So it's been thought of for a
long time as a land of plenty,
land of wealth, a land
of hope, and anticipation
of what a new world can be.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our highlight series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.